we are missing quite a few of our
members so if everybody here in the
public could just give us a few minutes
to
wait for them to get here and then we
will go ahead and start the hearing so
I'll go ahead and open it now and then
I'll just go and a
recess
I apologize for being late I know your
time's valuable um we're going to begin
uh shortly could we please rise for the
Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for it stands one nation under
God
indivisible okay with that we are
beginning our continuing series on uh
bail reform and bail bills and I believe
we have several speakers to address us
today from the counties and I would
invite what we get for a
superintendent superintendent Henry
please
morning everybody superintendent Henry
from Rockham County Jail how are you
well how are you
good by all means the floor is yours
yeah sure I didn't know if you had
questions of me that's what I'm here for
of well I we had assumed that you might
want to tell us a little bit about um
how Bale interacts with your agency what
um what happens what you do what you see
happening now sure um so bail in general
it's
uh traditionally again this is I've been
around for almost 20 years uh over 20
years somebody gets picked up for a
crime and then they can either get bail
commissioner at a PD or even at the jail
uh for us the way it works it is
bail commissioner comes out meets meets
with the uh individual and from there
they decide what bail it might be um do
the paperwork uh collect money all those
type of things from the individual and
then from there if they're being
released we release them could be PR
bail it could be cash bail if they have
cash show up or if not it's prevented
detention then they stay with
us I know you guys were look a couple
things uh magistrates at one time um but
I don't know if you're still that's
still something out there which is great
because we have a lot more to talk about
uh I know you're looking at 13 um crimes
that would be automatically would have
to stay that wouldn't be that wouldn't
really affect the jails because we have
people stay anyways um so we're we're
kind of used to
that biggest thing for us is we lack of
bail Commissioners that is the the huge
problem and I've seen that again over 20
plus years I worked with bail
Commissioners and part of it is is
them not getting paid be honest with you
I work at bail Commissioners there was
,500 to $2,000 that they were not
reimbursed for and they tried way back
when to get the courts to help them out
and they said no so you had a lot of
people leave because of that even though
it's a it's a small fee but we're waking
these people up in the middle of the
night to come on out over and over again
and to do it for free was always very
frustrating for them so a way for them
to actually obtain their fees I think
we'd actually get more bail
Commissioners which is helpful because
then people can if they don't belong
inside the jail or uh again bail is just
to make sure they're showing up a court
so if they have that opportunity then
they should have that opportunity and
not have to put on a police officer make
a decision of hand summons or sometimes
the PDS will have to go no bail and do
it themselves and that means they have
to show up at court and justify that um
because we because we can't find a bail
commissioner and that is prevalent in a
lot of places a lack of bail
Commissioners so so there's that um um
anything else you guys had was there
other questions on that sure um if you
could speak to what what um what do you
have in in your facility to deal with
people that um either are suffering from
substance abuse when they arrive or from
mental health problems sure so which is
we'll say 99% of people coming in either
on on something are they cooccurring so
we have a lot so for dealing with those
individuals um again that's is always
tough why even doing the booking
procedure or sometimes even bail
commissioner because they're not in the
right State of Mind is also difficult
where we sometimes not able to do a bail
commissioner first and once they either
come down from their their drugs or
alcohol they get still have another
opportunity to do bail when they're able
to be coherent for like us for
Rockingham County we do have 24hour
medical care um some places do not
Mental Health Care is not 24 hours a day
but what every place does have is a
screening tool we use for um uh for
health purposes you know how the
whatever's going on that they need for
medications those kinds of things and a
mental health evaluation and that's 247
we always everybody gets screened in if
again I will also preface if we're able
to there are individuals we're not able
to work with them yet that we have to
put it aside and wait until they can
calm down and keep coming back to them
to see where they're at but once they're
booked in we use those tools
uh the health evaluation tools will go
to medical and then if it's 24 hours a
day seven days a week my medical will
come down afterwards and actually do a
full screening if medical is at another
place only during the day or first and
second shift they'll come down and do
that screening in the morning if it's
mental health evaluation like we do the
sheets what it does it adds up to a
certain amount of points those kinds of
things and it gets flagged in the mental
health department and again if they're
still there the next day they also will
be seen by mental health to evaluate
them and that can rise to a whole other
level of different things just because
somebody's like say a protective custody
or even PR
bail it could rise to a level where
we're doing an IA process and to get
them help and that could stall process
from
leaving um for just so you know personal
recogniz and bail if they do not have a
ride in the middle of the night none of
us release them of which technically
speaking they're free individuals but
but back in the day there was an
individual released from a jail under
under that went out in the middle of the
road sat down and was hit by a vehicle
because they wanted to commit suicide so
we no longer do that to help these
individuals out which is pushing our
what we're doing but again I'd rather go
to court on safety all of us the
superintend rather go to court on safety
for for an individual rather than having
them go get injured so if I could just
on that so you're talking strictly about
people that have been screened to have
mental health problems us a person who's
fine in released on PR if they have a
ride or not they're free to walk off or
if they have a ride not not in the dark
we won't let them walk off just in the
dark on the r without a ride because I
know where you're located yeah we all
are highway right there yeah kaas County
Mill nowhere so yeah if they don't have
a ride whether they're they're mentally
ill or not we won't because of it's it's
just too dangerous for them and for us
and again I'd rather be you know Tried
by you know Tried by you know a jury
rather than Carri somebody so we all
have taken that stance many years many
years to do that that's only at night
time and the daytime daytime they they
can depending which jail you're at my
jail doesn't allow people to just walk I
actually pay for taxi voucher
rides I'll you know a lot of money but
so um along the same questioning with
the mental health um say for example you
get someone that comes in who may be
schizophrenic and they're off their meds
which is why they're
there they
are they seen that night or or is it the
next day by mental health and and if so
when how do you know what meds are on do
you have access to the to the um to the
prescribe to the prescriptions they have
based on the electronic system or how do
you how do you figure that out you got a
couple things one if they come with any
medication that um is bagged and then
we'll go to Medical uh because they'll
have to go back and confirm the
medications their doctors all those
kinds of things uh mental health usually
is only in during a day and not
everybody has seven days a week so um or
like I do um so if somebody was a higher
level really need things there are
places to call in to evaluate that kind
of person especially if they're
experiencing a severe crisis um once
medical or mental health comes down
again depending on what you have um some
can wait because it's just they're okay
they're safe but if they're in crisis
they'll get somebody then they try to
work with that individual to find out
what information they can if that
individual is willing to sign a waiver
usually what they do so that way they
can call their doctors the pharmacy all
those kind of things they will backtrack
and find all their medications that
they're on to get them what they need if
they can't what we a lot of times will
do is do you have a relative we can get
holde they had you know sign off on the
that allow us to we'll get hold of a
relative those kinds of things they do
medical does everything they can to try
to
find what their history is and what
proper medication they can Beyond so
that transfers from basically the
corrections end to the the medical end
we let them do that and they do a good
job across the board I will say that
I've been I've worked from marrt County
I was superintendent of Carol County
with second smallest in the state to
Rocky ham County second biggest in the
state so I can tell you I have firsthand
experience with how that works and
that's pretty consistent all across the
board
okay and substance abuse um do you have
uh any kind of program to bring people
down who are going into a draws like the
Box Zone or things of that nature so
couple things the boxone stuff that we
what that would be more of we'd find out
if they're actually on it then you have
to go back the doctors make sure they're
really on it and all those kinds of
things and then they may maintain on
somebody who's just in protective
custody or even PR bail for over the
night are probably not going to get that
because we can't even show that they're
actually on it you can't give just give
it to somebody because they say it but
if they are um the the RSA 30b is pretty
clear um you know we we'd continue with
their medication
screen them for the medication those
kinds of things they would be continuing
on we all have some sort of tapers um if
they're going through some bad R drawal
withdrawals so your Medicals departments
um all have protocols we give
medications um you have anything from
not just medications but also like they
Gatorade everything else and we've come
a long way I mean over the years uh
wasn't medications we withdraw we just
try to make you as comfortable as
possible a lot of things have changed
over the years none of us want to deal
with a person who's in um being very
very sick and then which makes them very
angry and then makes them hard to deal
with and that's not what we want to do
we want to try make them comfortable as
possible to get them through because
it's not again our goal is Corrections
our goal is not punishment punishment is
the court you go to jail our job is to
make sure that you're going back to your
family or moving on to another facility
or whatever you're going to do so
there's a lot of protocols and I can
tell you in New Hampshire five are the
10 counties I'll have Prime care which
is a medical company
and they're NCCC certified which is the
gold standard of um so they actually
have an independent company come look at
them make sure they're doing the right
things
and they have wonderful policies and
protocols we have things called levels
which if you come in and you are with a
certain charge or crime or behavior you
maybe put on
a uh a one-on-one watch which means I
have to have an officer right there
could be level one watch which is every
15 minutes could be level two could be
level three so we have levels for those
that have mental health issues uh for us
and this what comes
into daily rate which is some of the
things that always get asked for there's
no way to calculate daily rate used to
be ADP versus your
budget now and I spoken to National
insute Corrections American jail
Association to try to figure out how to
calculate what it costs I can't if an
individual comes in tonight who needs
medical care
and one ambulance ride for me is
$1,700 so that person just cost me
$1,700 right right there if a person
comes in and that we now need a
one-on-one C person with them if you did
oneon-one 24 hours a day seven days a
week say they stayed that's 21 spots of
overtime for that individual plus their
Medical Care Plus their mental health
care and all those kinds of things so it
it's it's very hard to say what an
average cost is going to be are you able
to build Medicaid for uh any of those
things like the ambulance ride Services
if they happen to have it when they come
in which some do some don't uh if they
have private insurance we try to go
after it but most these people do not
have anything so no um you that is also
shut off 30 days after you're in anyway
so no um we I shouldn't say shut off
it's paused it's paused and then it's
able to turn back on 30 days before they
go so that whole time frame between we
pay for all of it and we usually pay for
the a rides now we only pay what I think
it's 1225 of the Medicaid rate
for hospitals and that kind of stuff if
an individual is actually admitted to
the hospital um we can go back and try
to get that reimbursed
admitted and that's where you start
splitting hairs with the hospitals they
can do an observation period if they do
observation we pay that we pay that bill
so sometimes we're in Conflict like you
admitting them or not because we need to
figure this out because I can get money
back and um so yeah we eat a lot of that
cost I mean it's very expensive
including medications I mean I had an
individual who uh his medication was
going to cost me a million dollars at
Carol County had to have it um thank God
another company came out of the woodwork
after I spent $200,000 in small little
Carol County which is way more than I
had in the budget uh to take that over
so costs are very tough to determine if
somebody has to stay on a EPC um and
continue with that that is very very
expensive it doesn't happen a lot in the
county happens a lot in the state um but
so kind of like um a school board almost
it's hard to predict but you don't know
if you have a special ed student come in
and can blow your budget right out of
the water I used to call him a sag
special a guess um on my budgets yeah
and that's basically what it is you can
take a pattern of what you had in the
past year you know couple years that
sounds pretty good it may build a little
bit in but one person can come in and
you know open heart surgery uh something
else that happened you just don't know
the overdoses that we have are in
Hampshire have gone through the roof we
use Narcan on a regular basis and you
take somebody as Narcan goes out an
ambulance needs more Narcan or Narcan
drip um and they need higher level of
care that's often we're sending people
to the hospital on a regular basis you
know yesterday was two people to the
hospital the people that we see are very
acute the acuy of mental health and just
um health issues has exploded um since
the about the middle of Co on and has
not stopped so that's has increased
across the board for all of us is there
any mechanism for you to get additional
funding from the state or from the
federal government to help offset some
of these costs that you're aware
of no I mean so not really I mean the
opiate
abatement um trust which I do sit on um
Sometimes some grants come out for there
we just did a round of reimbursement for
Medicaid assisted treatment back for two
years so some of us got some of that are
getting well once it makes through Gene
C we're make getting back some of that
cost but moving forward no there there
really isn't a
mechanism what about um
services from outside do do you have any
type of arrangement where um people that
come in there that may not have Medicaid
or something or or anything Social
Security any of that where services are
allowed to come in and help these people
or or talk with them or yeah so we have
a lot of report a lot of the communities
we also have we'll have the rapid
response team come in and work with
individuals if we need to have them put
into an
evaluation um most jails I think almost
all we have case managers will work with
these individuals um to get their
licenses uh try to get them set up with
their first doctor's appointment again a
protective custody inmate or just a PR
inmate is probably not going to get
these things we'll they're we'll give a
you know if we can give a pamphlet hey
you want a contact they're just not
there long enough for us to to Really to
do much besides care from why they're
there if they're there for any length of
time then we're able to try to give them
the first doctor's appointment try to
get them uh through their social
security anything they need that we can
our case managers will try to work with
them to get them hooked up as fast as
possible including housing we'll look
for housing form those kinds of things
it just depends if we have if they're
there for enough with us for but we
inside have a lot of that and a lot of
connections in the
community to the best of your knowledge
what is that like across all the
counties is it very inconsistent is it
yeah I would say it's very inconsistent
I mean you you go to the the northern
part of State there's the services
probably not there as robust as they are
down the state um I know like my friends
sub there he has made connections in the
community and and does what he can but
again it really just depends on what you
have in your community those kinds of
things so it's it's all over I would say
it's all over the map um do you work at
all with any pre-trial Services um in
other words a handoff to people who are
out on getting out on bail so Rockingham
County is a little different yeah we
have our own pre-trial service program
the the jail we pay for the program
itself oh okay um so we have a pre-child
program we also have adult diversion
program can you explain those to us
adult diversion that's done the court
recommend adult diversion we have one
lady that works with them they'll come
in they do check-ins and she has some do
some programs those kinds of things we
actually never really see them the
pre-trial program again it's
recommendations by the court for
somebody to be on pre-trial release
which would mean we would monitor them
and and and they would have to come in
do be tested on your analysis testing
see where they're at and all those kinds
of things now do you do electronic
monitoring yeah it's all they' all be on
electronic monitoring through
that different between us in other
places um because the jail owns it the
liability is on the jail and where my
people and me person are not indemnified
the counties that own the court owns it
are indemnified so like we get pushed
back from the some of the judges for
rocking in particular who are used to
some other Cy saying well why aren't you
putting large amount of people out
which if you look at some of these other
counties they don't even know where half
the people are it's NE here or there I'm
like because we own them we it's my
liability not the courts uh so we put
out the proper people if you have some
crimes that are not appropriate we don't
put them out there's also other criteria
you need to have housing and this and
that so it's it's a a bunch of stuff to
go through and that's normal of all the
programs but Rockham County in
particular we just they're ones we won't
put out that the court if they wanted to
take that if they took over our program
they could put more people out because
then they're they' be indemnified from
all those lawsuits when someone goes on
and does something heinous um well
explain that to me I'm a little confused
so if if the court says you are assigned
to
pre-trial the state court assigns it to
the county pre-trial the county pays for
it and the County's responsible for the
person and the county decides whether
they not they get out we decide because
we own the program decide if they get on
it's a recommendation from the court
okay um do they cannot make a the court
cannot make the jail pretty much do
right doesn't set bail it leaves it up
to you to decide whether they should be
out on pre-trial they'll make
recommendations that should be on
pre-trial release and then we will
determine under our program our criteria
if they belong out if the pre- child
program is owned by the court then
usually those people will just follow
what the judge's order says and here you
go the judges determined that but
because we own it we pay for it and it's
a high liability for us and the the
county taxpayer dollars they come back
and sue me and everything else we're
going to own that uh liability that's
why if it's goes to the back to the
courts they own that liability if
somebody goes out that's the way ours
Works we're a little different I think
we're the only one that actually pay for
it and some counties do not have a
pre-child program uh I know you guys
talking about next week but I'll just
throw this out one reasons why a lot of
counties and don't want pre-trial
program or don't have it there is no
tooth in a pre-trial
program I can't bring anybody back if
somebody violates in a pre-trial program
uh and should be back in the jail and to
do something severe I actually can't
bring them back unless they make if it's
a crime and I can call police officer
and great but if they're high doing all
kinds of stuff they shouldn't be doing
we don't have the authority to bring
them back you have to write a letter to
the court the court can make termination
to bring them back work they're on
probation probation can say you've
messed up you're going back to jail and
it could be for a short duration of time
which they do couple days of reassess
find what's going on the county program
we can't do
that uh so something looked down along
the road putting some language in there
saying that the counties they had a
pre-trial program they could bring them
back we could manage and handle people
better than trying to wait for the court
we could bring them back then work with
the court those kinds of things so
that's it's a it's a makes it difficult
on that kind of program when you don't
have really control but yet you're
supposed to oversee them and make sure
they're not doing well it seems kind of
pointless if you put somebody on a on an
ankle monitor and say you can't go here
and here between these hours and they do
it
anyway what do you do like
to the court and there yes which is very
frustrating yeah it's very I me it's
frustrating because you know you could
have a victim out there and they're not
in the zone they're not supposed to be
there now you can maybe it's our Zone
inclusive Zone supposed to be there or
it could be the court ordered 100 feet
you can let a PD know maybe they went
there maybe they'll go pick him up but
probably not that we have to send it to
court and let them violate and those
kinds of things but normally if it's
like a probation officer they just go
back and pick them up obviously you're
not doing what you're supposed to be
doing we need to reassess and figure out
what's going on and do you Lea with
parole as well we do we work with them
too um but again they have their own
pretty much their own program right um
but if they violate someone they bring
them and they drop them off and yeah
they can do a two things with them they
can violate them um well the viol and
bring them back and the way it works is
if they get a new charge they stay with
us while they go through a new charge
before they actually violate them which
that was a change
from probably eight maybe more nine
years ago got time flies where it used
to be if they were picked up on a
violation they go right to the state
prison but then there was some nice
downshifting where they would pick them
up on new charge put them to the County
facility where we get to hold them and
pay for them and then once they with a
new charge then then they get violated
and go to state prison so they can pick
it up it was some downshifting someone's
on state parole they commit a crime on
state parole state parole officer gives
them to the county you hold them until
they get found guilty or not guilty and
then based on that decision they violate
them then they go back to the state y it
used to be reversed years ago it was a
it was a downshift and there was
testimony at that time too that was
going to be a downshift to us to the
count I generally I generally push back
on the downshift concept but that that's
that's actually a real example yeah I
just been around long enough to
remember okay and I I'll speak for
rocking can of myself uh truthfully if I
had my way I would take two years you
know don't don't take us all
superintendant I I would take two figure
sentences and have our own probation
where most of us have gone to a 90-day
in-house treatment program um with step
downs and all kinds of stuff and if you
look at the research one year of after
care where you can actually have our
case managers follow in the community
make sure go to doctor's appointments
everything else um there's High success
those programs uh Sullivan County does a
great job they were they partner with
probation and the courts were all on
board to do it down there they get two
years probation first year they do the
program and then then step down if they
do well they cut down the they cut off
the
probation uh if counties had that then
we would have more control over those
two years which are shorter sentences on
a lot of different things and they're
not usually the higher violent crimes or
anything like that you'd actually have
more leverage to work with these
individuals because the more they're
longer they're clean the longer that
they're in the programs those kinds of
things the less likelihood that they're
going to reoffend and that does not mean
be inside the jail for two years that
means get them to go through the program
step down to work release step down to
home confinement but still having the
ability to be working with them if they
met and if they make a mistake um could
still stay out there or doesn't need
pulled back pulled back and go okay you
need come back in we need to restart
with some programs we need to start
looking this again we know that people
are going to fall off the wagon and but
how bad and what have they done and what
can we work them with that's just my Pie
in the Sky that's me definitely good
input
um back to the to the strictly the bail
issue
about do you have any idea first well
let's go back to your pre-trial what
does it cost that program to the county
pre-trial program yeah I look I mean I
have to look at my budget uh well we
have two dedicated full-time officers to
that pre- for us for the pre-trial
program
um beyond the electronic monitoring uh
most of bracelets we end up paying for
because it's it's cost effective
so two salaries plus the bracelets is
basically what's costing us and we have
end space so I'd have to look at the
budget exactly what it is but I could
get you that yeah if you wouldn't mind
the the bracelet I'm particularly
interested in I feel like that could be
better utilized across the state and let
more people remain out and continue
working if they were able to be
monitored can you give me an idea on the
cost and the scope of that program so we
monitor through the pre-trial program we
actually do monitor them so bracelets
cost anywhere from depending on what
they are could be up $10 a day for for
the bracelet and there's a couple
different ways I mean if the count
wanted to to pay for they could or the
individual a lot of times if they're
working it's charged to the individual
because they still get the opportunity
to be out in the community right
monitoring it just depends like we have
a preow program so my people do monitor
uh so the company doesn't monitor notif
no not the company doesn't monitor we we
monitor because we're the ones that have
to go tell the courts and everything
else and we're ones watching the
computer everything not everybody has a
program like that uh smaller facilities
will be tough because you don't have a
Manpower maybe to if you put a bunch of
people out somebody has to be either on
their phone tracking them and the
computer's tracking them and figuring
out where they are setting up those
zones bringing them in to tell them
where they can and can't go you bring
them in uh so often especially if
they're some sort of drug offense who do
your analysis test to make sure they're
not using new substances so there's
there's there's Manpower in this but
again I too believe that better off in
the community and doing some of these
things working with them and the jails
have a good opportunity I think to do it
because we're open 247 you can work with
an individual who may have a day job
and can't be pulled out to go get do
your analysis some other things so they
may be able to come in the in the
evening and vice versa um where some
other places you know 9 to5 we're done
so we're able to work with I feel able
to work with some others just because we
can make things work for them but in all
the jails across the state are open 24
hours a day yes we we canot
close
um are you aware of whether or not the
company that you deal with also offers
Services where they do the
monitoring um no I don't know companies
that offer the monitor I know in
Massachusetts their parole has a system
where I believe it's a third party that
monitors and notifies the parole
officers okay your parole is here or
there they didn't check you know they
might with something something explored
it's probably at a substantial cost I'm
sure anything can be done in money yeah
yeah okay thank you anyone uh on the
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman speaking of anything can be
done with money um
if there was the money to invest in the
community as well in terms of Mental
Health Services or uh other Community
Based Services that might be able to
catch those people with that issue
before they get to jail do you think
that that would help with the people who
are admitted to the prison and the
amount of people you're seeing with
substance abuse issues yeah absolutely
uh brick and mortar and you'll hear it
over and over again from all of us and
everybody else the state just LAX brick
and mortar for not just twofold here
getting out someplace to go so they can
get stable and move on we don't want put
them back in the same place they were
because they're just going to come back
two if there were places like
Massachusetts have where you can go and
show up because you're going in a mental
health crisis or other things or police
can bring you there where Specialists
are there for Mental Health crisis and
dealing with them uh would stop them
from coming inside the jail when they
come into jail I can't use four por
restraints we cannot forcibly medicate
anybody so you're dealing with a a
system is designed for for criminals
okay so and yes we do a lot of training
and mental health we try to treat them
kick gloves but there're just things we
can't do that other places can which are
more
appropriate it's there's a bunch of
other bills I've testify against so
seems to be more and more pushing out to
the jails and and away from other places
that actually specialize in this stuff
now don't wrong jails have we have put a
lot of money into specializing these
kinds of things but I but I'm not a
hospital we're not not a hospital those
kinds of things I it's because have a
you have a building in beds so people
see right and then and more pressure
being pointed out to do more but if
there was places like that that some
place that they could actually go to if
you read the protective custody statute
it used to say that somebody was
intoxicated you actually brought them to
a place those places don't exist anymore
so that's why the jails are now what the
other option is so if you bring those
kind of places back that they're
intoxicated they're in Mental Health
crisis those kinds of things that they
can be treated properly they can't from
there they become they're too violent or
they the crime says they have to go over
here but there is a huge faction over
that could go to place like that
absolutely can I get a followup Mr
followup yeah um and then in terms of
the bail commissioner issue uh in your
experience and I don't want to have you
speak for the court but in your
experience having worked with the court
a lot um why is the court saying no to
issuing the payment to the bail
Commissioners why is the court saying no
yeah well it's always been traditional
that the individual has to pay the the
bail commissioner codes fee for them I
think the court didn't want to pay the
bail Commissioners because it costs them
it will cost money there and then they'd
have to go after the individual who
didn't pay the cost so means they're
going to need to have somebody going
after and getting those reimbursed back
can I get another followup to that quick
yeah quick um wouldn't it make more
sense to have the court go after those
individuals then for them to Sure the're
only ones that have the the're the only
ones that can the bail commissioner
itself can't go
only on that would have the ability to
add to they could tax it on to their
restitution or anything else when they
went to court so there's what up more
opportunities there than there's a bail
single bail commissioner to do anything
right thank you Mr chairman yeah
representative
Pratt uh electronic monitoring device do
they make one that monitors drugs and
alcohol they make multiple different
ones I know alcohol there definitely you
can do alcohol there's things you can do
with their cars those kinds of things
there's a lot of Technology out there
there's some good
actually represent Pratt I just read an
article yesterday where there's one that
does uh it does drug somehow it I don't
know how it does it but so I'm sure it
costs a pretty penny too representative
Newman yeah I just have a quick question
about somebody who is arrested for
DWI and there are various degrees of
intoxication how how is that treated
when they come in to see the bail
commissioner and or the judge and what
what happens to a
person for DWI yeah so depends a lot of
times DWI are actually handled right at
the police department with a bail
commissioner um but if they come to
us we see intoxicate people all the time
if they're able
to speak coherently um we'll call bail
commissioner and they would just come in
sit down with them bail commissioner
goes all all the forms and all that kind
of stuff what they're eligible for those
kinds of things sen upal court date most
of those lot lot of times are just set
personal
recogniz usually that you're promising
to show up at Court thank
you if the but if the person appears too
intoxicated to understand the terms of
the bail what what do you do then so a
couple things uh for uh for the jails we
probably would encourage the person to
just wait a little bit um but if they've
already seen a bail commissioner which
sometimes does happen and no bail is put
on because the person's not able to
participate once they so up they still
have the opportunity again to you want
to see bail commissioner cuz now you're
in your right State of Mind to see bail
commissioner so they still have that
right
they're we'll say there's some rub with
some other law enforcement agencies and
stuff when you do do that because
they've already left but to be on the
safe side from almost all the jails be
like now we're the ones that have to
keep them and deal with them not other
outside agencies and I came from being a
full-time cop years ago so it's great i'
rest drop off and leave now I'm on the
other end I'm like oh it's not so great
when they have to stay um so we can get
them bail
um as best as possible because now
they're in the right State of Mind to
participate in that
process representative Stone thank you
in your experience how often do you see
violations of pre-trial release actually
having their bill revoked by the courts
after uh their incidents are documented
they're submitted obviously I would
assume there's a hearing that's held how
often are you seeing anyone's bail being
revoked for violating the terms of their
release talking bail or you talk pre you
said pre-trial because pre-trial is
different so got Bail uh not often
enough I I've seen people that you know
who violated their bail several times
and come back and it's not revoked or
maybe increased of what they have to to
do I past several years I've
seen a rise of people able to do more
crimes and break their bail without
having consequences of having to and I'm
not an advocate just so you know of get
more people staying in jail my job is to
put myself out of business that's if I
that's what it my job is to get people
corrected but at the same time the
frustration when you see somebody either
drive again or driving out the
suspension or going out committing
another
assault uh stealing again I know people
have considered the stealing now a low
level because it's you know they're
going for their drugs and stuff but when
they do it over and over again it's
still not it's not a victim of crime
somebody gets something stolen so we see
a lot of those repetitive over and over
and over again it takes a long time for
them finally them to revoke the bail
thank you do you have the ability to
track in other words you know how many
people are coming our repeat offenders
back to your facility are you able to
track the number of people that are for
example brought back while they're on
bail and then released again I don't
think we're able to track of I can tell
you who's come back we can track who's
come back in a facility it would be
difficult to track who's come back who's
on bail without actually opening
individual files okay
okay representative Ro thank you Mr
chairman thank you superintendent Henry
um chairman Roy basically just asked one
of the questions that I've been waiting
to
ask which was about
uh I guess for lack of better term re
repeat offenders if you will um and my
but my next question and I I realize
this
is kind of a an opinion if you will
but we're hearing from from some bail
Commissioners and we're hearing you know
obviously from all all sorts of people
testifying and one of the things we're
hearing is about
inconsistencies with with Bill
Commissioners so with that being said
and I don't know why I didn't ask
anybody else until now is there any kind
of a of a guideline where you know if
the person has been arrested for XY or Z
that you know this is like the general
rule of thumb for Bale
or is it just really up to that bill
commissioner it's so I had a hard time
speaking for them because it's not
something that that our side really
deals with okay I can tell you from
years of experience yes some of it is up
to the individual bail commissioner they
do get training from the courts um to
try to be have them consistent but I do
not believe that there is a matrix per
se that says you do this as many times
you get X um so do I think there's way
to be more consistent
sure if the courts put something
together I think and I think we can all
follow a matrix or something along those
lines if it was put together we do let
for a lot of things we do inside for our
assessments
so let me have a followup and to follow
up with that and kind of piggy back on
chairman Roy's question it was far as
you know somebody was out on bail and
now they've been rearrested and one of
the questions that I had asked um
somebody previously was you know
somebody that was out and you know they
were told you know don't do drugs don't
do alcohol and now they're rearrested
and what was that number do you see a
larger percentage of people being
rearrested you know that you know within
you know I would say a close period of
time or do you see more of hey I kind of
got out of jail free card you know
waiting to go and see the judge or is it
is it just like this revolving door
because we're hearing both right see
more revolving door people
get we'll put take this back to uh you
putting restraining order on it's just a
piece of paper says don't go do it and
we all and then people still go and
commit horrible crimes this piece of
paper says do not go drink do none that
blah blah blah and we they go do they go
do it anyways it's just a piece of paper
um so revolving door in short durations
of time seen quite a few people back on
th especially those kinds of stuff
that's put on their bail form clarify
what I heard so basically what you're
saying is the piece of paper is just
that and there really isn't any teeth to
what they're being what the conditions
are personal recogniz and bail is
doesn't have a lot of teeth and it it's
just a promise that you're going to show
up to court bail cash bail it's I mean
it hurts a little more because you're
going to be out of money so yeah it's
not again it's just a piece of paper
you're promising it does it work for
some people sure but do we see more come
in than not yes okay thank you thank you
very
much um you said you had um worked in
other counties before um some of them up
further up
north it's on my understanding that
there are a lot of police departments
out there well they don't even have
departments they just have like one guy
um how do they handle
transports do they leave their town and
go to the jail and their Town's just not
covered I mean or do you ever offer or
do the counties ever offer the ability
to go pick up that prisoner for them
nine out of 10 times it's the town that
brings him in you know when I worked for
Whitefield PD way back when it was just
a one one car driving up to Coos County
hopefully another town we try to get him
to
cover depending on what Sheriff's
Department you have some are more active
some are not um because they're more on
the Civil side sometimes they may have a
car that would work with that local PD
but most of the time it is just a local
PD coming to the jail which is also a
strain they're they want to get back on
their town as fast as possible mhm but
at the same time as a jail we need
paperwork done we need a bail set we
need all these other things so it's a
competing harms type thing sometimes you
know sometimes P just want to drop them
off and go you get a bail commissioner
well we can't because we're not the ones
that can tell what happened and
everything else and blah blah blah so
having more bail more bail Commissioners
readily available is a huge uh help for
those local Peds a lot of times we're
waiting for quite a long time and and
your town is not covered especially
those small towns
does the
sheriff because you guys patrol all of
Rockingham County do do the sheriffs
have the ability to pick up coverage for
the town if they can't transport for
them I like to speak for the sheriff we
don't you know I don't work for his
department but uh he does he have the
ability sure he does and he does work
Rockingham count in particular it's a
very large department so they actually
have some cars and they will work with
some of the local PES if they're around
but your other some of the smaller
Sheriff's departments again they're
they're doing civil stuff mon they may
have a car if they're lucky out in the
evening or even if they have one uh some
of the sheriff's department like where I
was before at Carroll County uh the
sheriff up there has partnered with
several towns and actually they pay to
have coverage through the Sheriff's
Department so there is some of that and
depending what hours they're doing I
don't know so there's hybrids out there
different
things any further
questions seeing seeing none we really
appreciate that um if you could get that
information to me regarding the cost of
your program your pre-trial program I'd
be interested to see what that cost you
no problem thank you thank
you ask share the transation oh you I st
that too yeah I'd be stealing stuff um
do you have anyone else tathy not today
okay telepathy going on yeah okay so um
is there anyone else here that wanted to
testify
today seeing none we're going to just
take 10 minutes to uh regroup and figure
out what we're going to do and then
we'll take it up
again
e
that will be all the witness testimony
we have for today so we're going to be
wrapping up shortly I just wanted to um
for the benefit of the committee and
everyone else um I'm sure you feel the
same way I do the further we open this
chest the more we find things popping
out at us that we had not participated
or no one has thought of um I'm
contemplating um asking the committee to
take one of these bail bills that we
have and create a study commission not a
committee that only has a year to come
up a
commission uh and call it a law
enforcement Summit where we bring the
sheriffs the police the every the um the
defense bar the Attorney General
everyone that judges into a room
and don't let them out until white smoke
comes out of the roof because there is
um such a disconnect between what
happens in different parts of the state
that your involvement in the criminal
justice system is almost like playing a
lottery um you could get lucky and win
or not and unfortunately we're talking
about people's lives we're talking about
victims we're talking about offending
we're talking about everyone and um if
we even if we can't afford the best
criminal justice system in the country
we can certainly afford an orderly one
and a uniform one and that would be the
goal I believe of this commission so
I'll be asking the commission I mean the
committee to consider that as one of the
bills that we have retained um I will be
scheduling a public hearing because it
is non gerine to the original one of the
bills so look for that coming up in the
very near future because we still are
under the deadline of having it out by
the beginning of November
anyone else wish to make a comment
before I
close if not next week um Thursday and
Friday we have two very um book days of
people coming to speak to us um we have
more people um from the counties who run
the pre-trial programs so we can
understand what that entails what it
costs um what a best practice might
be and just for
your future planning purposes the 20th
of October will be the last day we hear
any witness testimony after that we will
definitely be having uh the remaining
several meetings will be to make sure we
have everything on paper and ready to
submit to the clerk I believe it's the
3rd of November we're going to meet as a
the full committee to offer our
recommendations to the full committee
for a vote so that's where I'm at um any
questions or concerns representative
rhods thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to say that in chesher County we
do have these diversion programs we have
uh the pre- court we have the drug
diversion we have the youth diversion
you know depending on what age you you
find yourself starting to get into
trouble and they're working quite well I
I did send an email while we were
listening to superintendent Henry um
asking our County controller if he would
send me those parts of the budget in an
email I do have them at home I was just
hoping maybe they would come over while
we were sitting here and I will share
with the committee what program chesra
county has and their
cost um because if you know Rockman
county has a few he you know my
understanding was he was stating is
they're working very well for for that
County as well so I will bring that and
share with the committee you know
basically the cost and how many people
and so forth see if that's helpful yeah
absolutely that would be helpful I think
that we need to look at Best Practices
and whether they be in this state or not
um I'm not a fan of Reinventing wheels
so we need to look at the best practices
across the state I'm not sure that the
pre-trial um program will be something
we'll be able to reach into um with this
it may be something that has to be dealt
within the study commission just because
of the expense and and um technical
nature versus the time we have left but
it's something that will be addressed I
think in that study commission a lot of
times you'll see a study commission
that'll say study the um the
interoperability of uh criminal justice
in New Hampshire we're not going to do
that we're going to spell out exactly
what we want the study commission to
address bail substance abuse using the
criminal justice system to deal with
mental health things of that nature um
so there's that with that um I will see
you all next Thursday enjoy your long
weekends